since it's been so long since we saw
these characters on screen even hardcore
fans might need a refresher course
before heading to the theater for their
new adventure but don't worry we've got
you covered with this look at everything
you need to know before you grab your
tickets for Toy Story for Toy Story just
wouldn't be what it is without its two
leads so of course some answers back as
Woody and Tim Allen returns as Buzz
Lightyear but it isn't just those two
that helped give so much heart to the
world of Toy Story and luckily just
about every character in the Toy Story
universe is coming back for the fourth
film but there are plenty of new
characters to look forward to as well
like an overstuffed toy box it seems
there's always room for some new
characters for us to fall in love with a
huge part of the narrative of Toy Story
4 seems to be centered on four key boys
by Tony Hale who seems to be in the
midst of an existential crisis about
whether or not he's truly a toy Jordan
Peele and keegan-michael key also joined
the film as bunny and ducky a pair of
stuffed animals who joined forces with
woody and friends while Christina
Hendricks will join the cast as a
character named Gabby Gabby a vintage
baby doll who commands an army of
ventriloquist dummies and an antique
mall and appears to be the central
villain of the film the extra weight for
Toy Story 4 may have been frustrating
for fans but it helped her timing a line
in at least one crucial way
Keanu Reeves voice workers new character
Joo kaboom arrives in the midst of a
career revival for the Hollywood veteran
it's just another reminder that Reeves
can handle pretty much any type of role
and as the Pixar brass discovered
shortly after arranging a meeting he
gives us all to any character even the
ones made out of plastic director Josh
coolly told Entertainment Weekly once
Keanu came to the table he was just
asking all these great questions about
the character it made us realize we
weren't digging deep enough for his
character and there's a real opportunity
to have him support Woody's story in a
much bigger way we used to revealed that
digging deeper included building out a
touching backstory for Juke a Canadian
stuntman sold to kids with promises the
toy might not have been able to fulfill
[Music]
please explained Duke let his kid down
when he couldn't do what a commercial
said he could so he's a wounded person I
wanted him to have a real sensitivity
and a soft heart he may have noticed one
surprising returning cast member of Toy
Story 4 Don Rickles the voice of mr.
Potato Head not that Rickles performance
needed changing it's one of the most
entertaining side characters on the
franchise
[Music]
you would not believe what I've been
through tonight
however Rickles died in 2017 as the
script for the film was still being
written it's signed on to be a part of
it but he was unable to record any lines
for the new film after his passing
Rickles family reached out to Pixar and
asked if there was any way that the late
comedian could still be a part of the
film in an interview with Entertainment
Weekly director Josh Cooley confirmed
that there was plenty of material to
bring Rickles back for one more go
saying we went through G's 25 years of
everything we didn't use for Toy Story 1
2 3 the theme parks - Ice Capades the
video games everything that he's
recorded for mr. Potato Head and so I'm
very honored that they asked us to do
that and I'm very honored that he's in
the film nobody can replace him at the
end of toys Story 3 and he decided it
was time to move on from his childhood
toys and pass them along to bunny
inducing tears for about the fifth time
during the film Toy Story 4 were
reportedly pick up with what sounds like
a flashback to a time between the events
of Toy Story 2 and Toy Story 3 a time
when Bo Peep was still around if you
recall that she was absent without much
explanation in the third film yeah we've
lost friends along the way
we z and etch and Bo Peep yeah even even
though those who have seen the beginning
of Toy Story 4 indicate that it will
fill in many blanks about where Bo Peep
disappeared to and what Woody Buzz and
the rest of the toys have been up to
since we last saw them movie Webb writes
that the main events of the film take
place nine years after the first scene
bringing us back to the main events with
woody and the gang adjusting to their
new life with Bonnie Toy Story 4 has
been in the works for quite some time
and not just due to the fact that
Pixar's animation process and attention
to detail takes a long time to complete
the film has actually gone through a
series of writing and directing changes
since it was first announced in 2014 the
original directing duo was cut in half
when John Lasseter stepped down but
that's just one of several behind the
scenes shake ups the film has also been
through a number of writers and even saw
Annie a total rewrite at one point
rashida Jones and Wilma Cormac were
originally in charge of the story but
they walked about the same time Lasseter
stepped down from his role as a
co-director
it's too bad for Pixar that the delays
push back Toy Story 4 so far but we did
get the delightful Incredibles 2 to fill
the space not a terrible second choice
in the original
of the script at Toy Story 4 was billed
as a romantic comedy Pixar president Jim
Morris told Disney Latino in 2015 that
Toy Story 4 would still follow the arc
established by previous chapters and the
franchise but it would also follow its
own path and tell a totally different
type of story
according to Morris that the film won't
focus much on the relationship between
toys and children but would instead to
pick the love story between woody and Bo
Peep this may be an indication of why
the studio reached out to Jones and
McCormick who had previously written the
film Celeste and Jesse forever however
in the interim the script has gone
through some major changes since it was
originally conceived and it seems
possible that Toy Story 4 may revert it
back to some of the more familiar
storytelling beats the series is known
for Jessie let's go save a spork
considering that Toy Story 3 seemed to
wrap up the franchise on a perfect note
many fans were surprised to hear that
Pixar was making a fourth film it might
be hard to believe there's another great
story to tell here but according to the
film stars Toy Story 4 is the most
emotional chapter in the series Tim
Allen who plays Buzz Lightyear appeared
on the talk and told the hosts that he
actually struggled to get through the
final scenes of Toy Story 4 due to their
emotional weights I got oh he's just
getting emotional so I don't want to
give it away but this is a incredibly
great story
some hangs who voices woody Eckerd those
sentiments telling the Chris Evans show
that he could barely even read his lines
on the last day when I went in for my
last day of recording I wanted to have
my back to them I didn't want to see
them and I didn't want them to I wanted
to pretend they couldn't see me it could
be easy to dismiss Hanken allen's
comments they're hyping their upcoming
film after all and they've played these
characters since 1995 of course it was
emotional for them however their
response to an early screening of Toy
Story fours opening act seems to
indicate that this is more than just a
couple of big stars trying to put butts
in seats in April 2019 and Disney
surprised the audience at CinemaCon by
showing the first 17 minutes of the film
and it sounds like Hanks and Allen
aren't just paying lip service for their
comments essentially it sounds like you
may need to see Toy Story 4 more than
once as you might be crying too much the
first time around to catch every detail
one couple my own check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]